I was talking to Jeff Bridges okay and
he said when he did Iron Man he said
there was very little script right which
shocks the hell out of me and why is
there so little script I mean those
comic books isn't that scary there's so
many comic books that have storyline
yeah well here's what I think he meant
is that we actually had a really good
story which is why the movie was
successful and then day by day favro and
myself and Jeff and we would just sit
around and and I would I would ball up
the sides for the day and throw them
against the wall and then Kevin feige
would say okay good morning and then we
would try to make a better version of
the scene which is actually why it
really kind of came off the screen I
wouldn't recommend working that way some
movies it's really important that you
follow the script because the other
actors have to follow along as well
right they need to know past a certain
point it's disrespectful if you're just
like man you know my [__] is real let's
just let's just on the cuff and whatever
I could swear at times you're ad living
because you're so [__] n at this
thing this acting thing I mean you you
just seem to be spewing out these words
and uh I don't know did you adhere to
the script completely or did you do a
little I have trouble with that uh Todd
Phillips who I did one of my favorite
movies due date with said uh it's
nothing personal I'm just allergic to
paper so when you got to let's say an
Iron Man the the thing I heard was that
Gwyneth patro was upset because she
couldn't keep up with you ad living are
you aware of that I I don't believe
that's true no because she
she's we can definitely go toe-to-toe
she with ad libing yeah and so when
you're ad living the the director's at a
at a at a sort of a disadvantage because
he don't even know where to put the
camera when you're on a roll right well
what Fabro would do is he would just do
French over so there's a camera on her
and a camera on me that way it's easy to
cut together and he would say great that
that's starting to feel a little bit to
like you know uh waiting for guffman so
just be specific about what you're
saying and and and wait to imp improvise
until you're kind of at the end of the
scene and she's walking away or whatever
Iron Man's a pretty amazing movie but
like but they'll never nominate a guy
for a best actor if he does a cartoon
movie or a superhero movie right is is
is there a bias against that um well I
mean Heath Ledger uh was a uh was an
exception I mean I don't I don't blame
him you know I guess it would depend I
mean somebody has to do something really
really special when you were uh
nominated for chap yeah you didn't win
that year you didn't win the the Academy
Award you deserved it that year didn't
you well if you think about it Pacino
was great in sent of a woman and he'd
been I don't want to say looked over but
he'd been nominated and not won a few
times I suspect I will win during a year
that somebody else really deserves it
I'll have no problem be pay yeah you'll
say someone else deserved it but I've
gone through this so [__]
you